now I'd like to introduce you to today's
featured presenter Michael Benin Michael
Benin is a managing director at the
Stanford global project Center
developing new initiatives for the GPC
and managing their student programs and
industry affiliations Mike's research
areas of interest for the Center and
work experience are in public sector
finance infrastructure and real estate
investment and project organization
design Mike serves as a captain in the
US Army and the US Army Corps of
Engineers for five years leading
engineer units managing projects and
planning for infrastructure development
in the US Iraq Afghanistan in Thailand
Mike received a bachelor's degree in
civil engineering from the United States
Military Academy at West Point and
received an MSC II an MBA from Stanford
University and by the way if you like
what you're hearing today in Mike's
presentation you may also be interested
in taking his Stanford Graduate course
on global project finance this being
offered this upcoming winter quarter
Mike will talk more about the class in a
moment but we want to flag that
enrollment is currently open until
December 11th so feel free to visit the
SCPD site to learn more about the course
and enroll and now I'll turn it over to
Mike so I've got a lot of material to
cover in a short period of time but
first I'll just take a couple minutes to
plug my research program program and the
course so I work at the Stanford global
project center so we're an
interdisciplinary research center at the
University and we kind of work between
the different department silos at the
University to conduct interdisciplinary
research and our topic is on innovation
in infrastructure finance and
development so we like to frame our
research program as covering a broad
spectrum and on one end of that spectrum
we have institutional capital okay so on
one end of that spectrum we have
institutional allocations to
infrastructure so an institutional
investors such as a pension fund or a
sovereign wealth fund more recently some
of these institutional investors have
created allocations to the asset class
so we do research
on that trend within the industry and
the risks associated with infrastructure
allocations on the other end of that
spectrum we do work on government
policies and practices and
infrastructure development so some of
these include procurement practices what
I'll be talking a little bit about today
in the United States and others include
public policies or in and around
infrastructure development and finally
we do case based research on the
projects in which that institutional
capital is invested in infrastructure
and lastly we also have a program on
innovation and infrastructure
development and the trend of cities
towards participating in the digital
economy now for for a quick overview of
my course which is starting in January
so global project finance really covers
that that whole spectrum of
infrastructure development and project
risk so part of the course is focused on
the basics of project structuring and
development some of the concepts we'll
talk about today and then we also have
modules on project risk assessment and
then a large module on infrastructure
investment so most of our class sessions
involve a topical lecture by me and then
a guest presentation from an industry
executive there the head of a public
procurement agency for infrastructure or
an infrastructure fund manager or a
project developer financial advisor or
even the manager of a pension portfolio
the course objectives are generally to
prepare students for a career in in
project finance and infrastructure
development writ large and for our
assignment for the course we develop a
financial model and a risk assessment
for an infrastructure project and we
develop components of it over the course
of the quarter this year it's going to
be a toll road investment
so onto what project finance is so
project finance involves the ring-fenced
financing of an infrastructure asset
based on the micro economics of the
project itself as opposed to the sponsor
balance sheet or the the city or
government's balance sheet so
infrastructure of projects they they
they have a few distinct tasks that are
required to complete them and manage
them over the long term so they have to
be designed built financed and then
operated and maintained under
traditional infrastructure procurement
the government essentially hires
companies to complete all of those tasks
or it uses internal staff to complete
some of them but it generally procures
them separately and then manages the
interfaces between those contracts under
a project finance or as it's also
referred to as a public-private
partnership or a p3 essentially the
government procures one contract for a
private partner to complete all of those
tasks and then manage the interfaces
between them so governments usually use
this procurement model the the prime
driver is to transfer the risks of
infrastructure development to that
private sector partner so infrastructure
projects are some of the most risky
enterprises that governments undertake I
like the bucket the risks associated
with infrastructure development into
into three buckets so on one it can of
course take much longer to build than
expected and go way over budget and
those are commonly correlated I can also
cost more to operate and maintain the
asset and then the the originally the
government originally forecast and then
finally for projects that are funded by
a user fee such as a toll road there can
be lower demand than what the government
originally expected that could cause a
lack of funding in the future so
governments as I mentioned generally use
this procurement model to transfer risk
to the private partner in developing and
maintaining an asset so there's a few
criteria that we recommend for
governments
or project sponsors to consider when
they're assessing a potential project as
a potential for project finance so the
first of those is simply scale larger
projects generally entail more risks so
this procurement model is really mostly
suited to larger infrastructure projects
the second factor is general project
risk so has the sponsor done one of
these projects before how did that go
it's a particularly unique project where
there might be significant
O&M risk or construction cost risk the
third factor is flexibility so because
these project finance generally entails
a longer contract generally if there's a
need for flexibility due to the
technology change or other factors this
procurement model might not be a good
fit for that because it's generally used
for longer term contracts and then
finally the last factor is innovation
so this procurement model because it
combines construction and operation and
maintenance into one contract there's
opportunities for innovation for the
contractor that's building the asset
because they have to both build it and
operate and maintain it in long term so
that means they might make decisions
during construction to optimize for
lifecycle cost instead of just the
initial cost to build the asset
so this slide shows the many parties
involved in a complex infrastructure
project and how they relate to one
another under a project finance
structure so generally a special purpose
vehicle or an SPV is created with the
sole purpose of building and maintaining
the infrastructure project the SPV will
have equity investors it will arrange
for financing to build the project and
then it will also have contracts with
many contractors and or operators needed
to build the project it'll also have a
project development agreement with the
sponsoring government so onto our topic
for today so to get straight to the
point this this procurement model isn't
used in the United States at the same
rate as it's used in other developing
economies globally so I like Canada and
Australia as good comparators to the US
because they're also large landmass
developed economies and federal
democracies and this chart shows the the
usage of this procurement model in
Australia and Canada both in terms of
the capital attracted and the number of
projects compared to the US so it's
pretty clear that it's use much less in
the United States which by population of
course has a much larger economy than
Canada Australia the question is well
why why hasn't this model picked up in
the United States well I think this
chart shows that it's not due to demand
so this chart shows the all of the
transportation and social infrastructure
public private partnerships that have
been procured in the United States and
it's sourced from an industry
publication so that the start of each of
these bars indicates the start of the
procurement process from the sponsoring
government so typically when a
government pursues one of these projects
it starts by issuing a request for
qualifications or RFQ to potential
companies that would compete for the
project the end of this bar
his commercial clothes or when the
government effectively finds a contract
with that infrastructure developer to
then go and finance and then build the
project for the red bars that the end of
the bar is commercial clothes or the
contract signing for the gray bars it's
when the project was cancelled so I
think this chart indicates a couple of
trends one is that demand for this
procurement model in the United States
is certainly increasing you can kind of
see that because by the start of
procurements kind of accelerating over
time what's also very clear from this
chart is that successful
excuse me successful procurements are
not being completed at that same rate so
in general this procurement model does
take a little bit longer to procure in
the United States when you compare with
other developed economies like Europe
but what makes the u.s. particularly
unique is the prevalence of project
cancellation so you can see a lot of a
lot of gray on this chart so this chart
further illustrates what I think is an
explanation of this trend in the United
States so this shows a breakdown of
infrastructure spending both by capital
projects or spending for new
infrastructure and operations and
maintenance it's also broken down by the
federal government and then our state
and local governments so I think this
chart debunks a bit of a myth about US
infrastructure so a lot of media reports
have indicated that you know part of the
problem with the u.s. infrastructure is
that essentially that politicians don't
prioritize infrastructure enough in the
United States and this indicates to me
that this is only partially true mainly
for our federal government state and
local governments on the other hand are
actually increasing spending in real
dollars to infrastructure and they're
particularly increasing it to
maintenance and so there's been a big
shift essentially in responsibility in
the United States from primary spending
primarily by the federal government
to spending by state and local
governments this slide indicates part of
my explanation for why this procurement
model of using project finance hasn't
picked up in the United States as it has
in other developed economies so to
explain this rather quickly
this chart shows infrastructure spending
over time both on Capitol projects and
on on maintenance projects and so we use
an institutional explanation for the
unique circumstances of infrastructure
development in the United States as it
relates to project finance so
essentially what I mean by that is a lot
of our institutions and by that I mean
our public agencies for developing and
maintaining infrastructure at the state
and local level were formed during very
high levels of spending by the federal
government and most of that spending was
focused on capital cost now federal
spending is still primarily oriented
towards capital costs but the the the
world that we exist in in the United
States is a much different place than
what in the decades following World War
Two when heavy spent federal spending
was supporting capital costs and in our
public institutions were essentially
designed for that world as opposed to
the situation that we're currently in
with that broad shift and responsibility
towards our state and local agencies so
part of our explanation is that our
public institutions in the United States
primarily at the state and local level
aren't really designed to manage
procurements using project finance which
has to account for all of the lifecycle
costs of of an asset as opposed to just
capital costs which are supported by the
federal government
so this is my last complex chart for the
debt for today so this is that same data
on public-private partnerships
transportation and social infrastructure
a broken down by state so the x-axis
shows the number of projects that have
been procured the size of each bubble is
the relative amount of capital that the
state's been able to attract using this
procurement model and then the y-axis is
the average procurement time for
projects in that state now I use this
chart to illustrate basically the power
of institutional change for public
agencies in in developing a new
procurement model like project finance
so every state that has procured more
than one of these projects essentially
has undergone some form of institutional
change in its public agencies just in
highlight a few so Texas Florida and
Virginia have all created p3 offices
within their departments of
transportation with varying levels of
autonomy Colorado has created the
high-performance transportation
enterprise which procures project in it
stayed Indiana created the Indiana
Finance Authority which has procured all
of its p3s and then the city of Long
Beach is a pretty unique example and
it's actually our our case study for
this morning has procured two of the
last three public-private partnerships
in the United States just by excuse me
in California just by one city alone and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a minute so none of these agencies
would be a kind of fully autonomous
alternative procurement agency like
those that have been formed in Canada
and Australia so I list a few here a
couple in Canada and a couple in
Australia that have been created to kind
of manage this very different form of
infrastructure procurement within their
states these are all States or
provincial agencies so all these
agencies are deaf
but they share some common
characteristics one is that they're not
sector based so they report either to
the Treasury or directly into the kind
of the state executive all of them
manage infrastructure procurements that
are that are completed using project
finance or another kind of alternative
structure for an infrastructure project
and these agencies are really designed
to have the internal resources and and
and capacity to manage those alternative
procurements as opposed to traditional
infrastructure procurement which is very
different they also all have a an
important role in reporting because
project finance involves the long term
contract reporting is especially
important both on a programmatic level
and these agencies issues specific
reports on their projects and so to kind
of explain the trend of Canada and
Australia adopting this procurement
model at a faster rate which we talked
about earlier all those projects were
procured by organizations like these so
what to do about this situation in the
United States well we have a few policy
recommendations if these are
specifically relating to federal policy
so federal support for mega projects is
especially important especially projects
that cross state or other institutional
lines lending support programs that are
already in place or that are ramping up
for project finance loans are also a
helpful policy program and these are
already in place enabling project
finance backed projects to access the
municipal bond market is also a good
federal policy and there's been a some
of these are in place and others have
been proposed more importantly I think
the federal government's institutional
support for for state and local
governments is especially important so
the Build America Bureau which is newly
formed and the transportation investment
Center these are both programs that help
state or local governments transition or
use this procurement model and they they
distribute essentially best practices so
those are strong initiatives and then
perhaps most importantly one of my big
federal policy recommended
recommendations is to create programs
that fund projects based on the
practices or innovative programs as
opposed to just the economic benefits of
the project itself so the new grant
program at the Department of
Transportation the infra grant program
is I think as a step in the right
direction
I think that program could be
significantly expanded to even provide
funding support for infrastructure
programs like the creation of a new
infrastructure agency as opposed to just
supporting an innovative project
so now I'll spend a few minutes talking
about our specific case study for today
this is the case of the Long Beach Civic
Center which is currently under
construction I really like this project
because it illustrates a lot of the
concepts that I've talked about in terms
of the project finance basis it straits
some procurement concepts for how cities
can use this procurement model and it
it's a good case for a lot of the topics
that we'll talk about in my course so
this project is essentially to tear down
and replace the city hall it's going to
tear it down it's going to the project
will build a new city hall to replace it
the project will also develop a new
headquarters for the city's Port
Authority a new library and a new public
park and once that project is developed
the company that's building it is going
to be responsible for operating and
maintaining the building's themselves
for a 35 year concession when the total
financing costs for the project were
about just over five hundred million
dollars so what made this project
successful procurement it's still under
construction currently well the the
reason the city was replacing its City
Hall was because back in 2005 the city
determined that it was seismically
deficient so the building was about 40
years old and it was rapidly decaying
and the city determined that they needed
to replace it because it didn't meet
Reisman code the city didn't replace it
initially but they conducted some
studies and in 2013 the city chose to
start pursuing a public-private
partnership and I think there's a few
reasons that the city chose this
procurement model as opposed to
traditional infrastructure procurement
one is that the first municipal
building p3 in the United States was
also developed in the city of Long Beach
so as a researcher on institutional
development within the infrastructure
industry I think that's an excellent
trend and that the the the city that
procured the second project using this
procurement model was of course the city
that that had the first use of this
procurement model the another factor
that led the city to use this project
finance to develop it this project was
that the the existing facility was
deteriorating at a much more rapid pace
in the city expected so there was a real
deferred maintenance problem so when the
city first came up with the cost
estimate to rehabilitate the old
building in 2006 they came up with an
estimate and then as they were
considering options for the
redevelopment of the City Hall they had
been escalating the cost to rehab the
old building at 5% in their in their
internal estimates when they reassessed
the building in 2013 their estimate they
found that an additional more than
thirty million dollars of deferred
maintenance had occurred on the building
so the building was deteriorating at a
much more rapid rate than they
originally expected the third factor for
this project and probably the most
important in kind of driving the city to
use this procurement model is the city
simply calculated their annual cost to
maintain the old facility so they came
up with an estimate that they were
spending around twelve and a half
million dollars a year on the old
facility and the city essentially just
went to the market and said we'll spend
twelve and a half million dollars a year
and no more on the old on the new
facility in terms of an annual payment
and that was they the city said it would
index that to inflation so how did the
city eventually get a much larger
project for that same annual
so instead of just replacing the City
Hall the project is going to build a new
Port Authority building a new library
and a new city park well part of the
factor there is that the old facility
was sitting on a lot of unused public
land so the developer of this project
once they complete all of those other
facilities they're going to be permitted
to develop some residential and
commercial real estate on some of that
unused public land so the city
effectively used some of that unused
land to offset the capital costs of
developing a new City Hall one of the
other important factors for this project
was a performance-based maintenance
requirement so the contractor that
builds the new facilities is going to be
responsible for maintaining them in the
long term and there's specific
performance requirements in the contract
I highlight a couple on this slide for
example elevators and and elevators out
for maintenance was a big concern of
city staff and so there's a specific
requirement in the contract for the
contractor to essentially repair
elevators that are down for maintenance
quickly and if they don't the city's
payments are reduced in fact if if
enough elevators are out then the city
can deem part of some of the upper
floors of the city hall not available
and thus not pay rent effectively on
that part of the building the
maintenance requirements also have a
hand back requirement at the end of that
35 year concession so essentially the
facility condition index or FCI has to
still remain 20 percent at the end of
that 35-year period so that essentially
means that the building it will be 20
percent deteriorated to put that into
context the exulting which was about 40
years old had an FCI of 52 percent and
the library the old library that's being
replaced had an FCI of 73 percent at the
time the
started to put those numbers into
perspective those are clearly in the the
teardown territory for a public building
and so the city at the end of the
concession period will be able to
inspect the facility to make sure that
it meets that FCI of 20% the last aspect
of this that I wanted to highlight was
the city was able to tailor the contract
based on the different public agencies
involved in the project so as I
mentioned earlier the city was having a
deferred maintenance problem so they
transferred more of the maintenance
responsibility to the private contractor
the pork facility is also going to be
maintained by the contractor but the
port didn't have the same maintenance
problem on its existing assets and it
wanted to perform more of the basic
maintenance using its internal staff or
contractors and so for the port building
the contractor is really going to be
more responsible for major maintenance
and rehabilitation as opposed to minor
maintenance the other of course unique
factor of this project is because it's
funded vienna on annual availability
payment the city effectively doesn't
make payments on the city hall or
library facilities until they're
constructed and the cities they're kind
of turned over to the city
that was my my case and topic for today
I hope it was useful and if you're
interested in learning more about these
concepts or our websites GPC
stanford.edu and it'd be it'd be great
to turn it over for some questions
thanks Mike as need for water
infrastructure funding increases do you
think bond funding less than fifty
million dollars will be in higher demand
also do you think bonds financing and
community involvement community members
participating in bond financing will
increase yeah that's a that's a great
question
I definitely think that of course as as
there's increasing demand for
infrastructure to investment in smaller
projects most of those projects and most
infrastructure generally is going to use
traditional procurement and of course
that that could entail some bond
financing so I do think that that it'll
increase in terms of the the other part
of your question just focused on project
sighs so this procurement model is used
in the the water sector and there's also
some other forms of alternative
procurement in which it would be used
for a long-term maintenance contract but
there wouldn't necessarily be private
financing and so and I think those
procurement models will increase is more
water utilities kind of turn to to kind
of long-term maintenance contracts you
know in terms of project size as I
mentioned this procurement models
generally used for smaller projects I
put a hundred million dollars as a good
floor just to illustrate the complexity
of the project where there is an
opportunity for smaller projects is in
project bundling so that would be a case
in which multiple utilities that require
an investment effectively bundle their
projects together and procure one
contract for all of the investments so
that would be the real opportunity for
project finance for those smaller
projects
all right thanks let's take another so
we have a participant asking are certain
types of infrastructure
it's more successful when using the p3
models and he's given example statistics
with toll roads airports etc yeah so in
general I would say the the projects
that entail more risk are better suited
to this procurement model so a project
such as a toll road that has as funding
risk if there's not enough drivers for
the road that entails additional risk
and therefore this procurement model is
a strong fit for for that sector
airports is interesting the the I
mentioned the u.s. is an outlier for
this procurement model and airports is
the one sector where the u.s. is
probably the largest outlier so most
airports that are you know internet and
other international developed economies
have been financed using project finance
and in those cases the the remuneration
for the investors in the airports are
essentially of course the the airline
fees that use the airport but then also
things like parking or rents from the
vendors and in the airport so there
isn't necessarily any single sector in
which this procurement model is a
particularly unique fit but in the u.s.
at least it's mostly been used for for
toll roads as I think be after mentioned
right so do these Canada or Australia p3
agencies have any special process for
expedited environmental approvals you
spoke about them in your presentation
yeah so I don't think they necessarily
have have a process for going around
traditional environmental approvals they
do have kind of the expertise to manage
the local environmental processes in
procurement
all right so essentially to make those
assessments during procurement I also
think they do some programmatic level
work so just for example
infrastructure New South Wales developed
and maintains a 25-year infrastructure
plan for for the state so that kind of
long-term perspective I think can assist
with kind of environmental approvals and
planning by simply laying out the the
actual needs specifically okay so like
stayin in the global perspective in
developing countries an example like
Indonesia emulate p3 approach for the
launch part large projects that you're
presenting here yeah and then developing
economies actually this procurement
model fairly often so that's that that
trend isn't is more a phenomenon of
multilateral Bank policy so several
multilateral lenders like the World Bank
require that project finance be used for
some of their infrastructure projects so
developing economies can certainly use
this procurement model it's been used in
it in Indonesia even for some smaller
infrastructure projects there and for
more recently for some very large
projects I guess be the requirement
really is that in using project finance
because the investment is really based
on the project's economics and not the
balance sheet or credit of the
sponsoring government for this
procurement model to be used as just
additional scrutiny on the project
itself so in order for this to be used
in a developing economy that government
there would simply have to adequately
appropriate funding for the project so
in that way project finance can be
almost a tool to create additional
scrutiny on the project itself to make
sure that the project economics and
risks make sense and this one
specifically is looking at your case
study that you presented who are the
equity and debt investors in the Long
Beach example and what guarantees did
they have against project cancellation
or asked another way who weren't the
risk yeah that's a really good question
and if you if you may have noticed on my
slide showing the completed and canceled
procurements there's a lot of
development risk and particularly in the
United States to answer your question
more specifically the I believe that the
contractor for Long Beach is an
infrastructure developer named called
plenary and so they would be the equity
I believe they actually arranged private
financing for so a private loan for
financing the project and that was just
based on their assessment of the best
way to finance the project for them in
terms of development risk it is a it is
a considerable factor and the companies
that work you that compete for these
projects do bear some development risk
mainly because as you can imagine the
costs for them to compete for the
project and develop proposals is quite
high I I'm not sure of the specifics for
a long beach but I believe they included
a stipend for essentially if they cancel
the project then the companies that were
competing for it get a small payment to
kind of recoup their the their costs for
pursuing a project and that's fairly
common for one of these procurements and
it's a good practice for government to
incentivize competition I think let's
see soapy trees look very attractive for
long term projects until the many states
face the challenge of blended state and
local funding requirements as well as
moving much of maintenance to operating
budgets how do you suggest
p3 success for a blended funding model
yeah that's a great question and I think
it certainly is a big factor it's you
know a great example of state and local
governments I think that are really
tackling that challenge would be Fargo
North Dakota currently
so they're they're currently procuring a
a flood protection p3 and project and
they're they're really going through the
the process between if two states
involved multiple municipalities and
they're really going through the process
to kind of determine who pays for what
and blending that funding so the answer
in terms of multiple funding sources or
funding coming from different pots is
essentially through the project
development process those disparate
agencies have to come together a good
another good example might be
partnerships Victoria one of the
agencies in Australia I mentioned so
they haven't practiced that for one of
these complex procurements they had they
form a project board and partnerships
Victoria sits on that board but so do
the other agencies and sources of
funding that are involved in the project
in any way and then the board is kind of
how those agencies communicate and
develop all the agreements necessary to
complete the procurement thanks so much
for all these great questions here's
another one considering this model is
fairly new I'm wondering if there are
any statistics on average financial
performance of the project from each
stakeholders perspective yeah there are
some aggregate statistics that are
published there in some ways though
there's not mostly of course these are
private investments so there might not
be necessarily be returns that are
reported by some of the companies or
funds that that invest in these projects
so some of that information is privately
held by companies of course but there
are some industry publications that
publish data on for example the the
funds that have been raised to invest in
infrastructure or and and for some
specific projects there's also
the public agency that procure ism might
publish funding support so for for data
like revenue opposed to investment
returns sounds like a lot of effort
needs to be invested upfront to create
the detailed contract considering there
are several stakeholders what about the
overhead related to enforcing the
contract yeah that's it that's an
excellent point so you know this the
using project finance has higher
transaction costs for completing the
procurement and those are those cost de
you mentioned in terms of sorting out
the project lifecycle plan essentially
so there there are additional
transaction cost and so when a
government considers this procurement
model essentially if you break down the
assessment to its most simplest form
what they're doing is they're they're
essentially valuing the risk that
they're transferring to the private
partner and they're weighing that
against things like the added
transaction cost to complete the
procurement or if the project has a
higher cost of capital using project
finance which it should they'll be
they'll be weighing that so they're
weighing some of their costs against the
risk that they're transferring through
the procurement and there was a second
oh the overhead to enforcing that that
that's an additional cost as well in
general most of these projects are
procured using a performance-based
contract but there's and so most of the
contracts that use this model
essentially permit the government to
conduct an inspection to make sure that
maintenance is being spent or required a
contractor to regularly report their
maintenance activities so there are some
costs there I think for a lot of these
projects it's that that cost in
particular is relatively low but it
really depends on the project itself
even broader question here from this
participant what would be the optimal
GDP percentage at company I mean a
country should assign to its
infrastructure yeah take on that
that's that topic is if you've read
academic literature on infrastructure
there's a lot of economists that have
spilled a lot of ink on that topic in
particular so it it does vary widely
there are some interesting studies
actually coming out of China now mainly
because China invests a much higher
percentage of its GDP in local
infrastructure than really any developed
economy and part of that is because
China's of course been rapidly
urbanizing over the last few decades but
there you see you know as a percent of
GDP I think it's getting up towards 8%
and whereas the u.s. between has been
between two and three percent of GDP I
don't personally I don't think there's
necessarily a right answer I think a lot
of a lot of the discourse in academia or
in public policy has been about
targeting that appropriate percent of
GDP invested in infrastructure when when
really infrastructure projects really
justify themselves based on their
microeconomics not macroeconomics so the
specific impacts of a particular project
really need to be assessed in order to
determine if it's going to be
economically beneficial but that at
least might give you a little bit of a
range in terms of the US which is on a
low the kind of the low end between two
and three percent towards an outlier on
the other end of you know upwards of
seven percent GDP alright if we have a
participant asking you to speak about p3
for aging energy assets such as central
plants yeah this is so project finance I
didn't you know my discussion today was
really focused on you know public
infrastructure so transportation and
social infrastructure but for energy
project finance has actually been used
in the United States and globally at a
pretty at a much higher rate so for a p3
for an aging energy asset I think that
the the the problem or the what would
need to be addressed in procurement is
really the source of funding for the
project so if if it's an aging
infrastructure asset that requires
rehabilitation the the government or
sponsoring body for that procurement
would really have to identify a funding
source so that might be if it's an
electric utility it might be part of its
rate base or some other sources funding
for the asset so it certainly is has
potential but really it comes down to
identifying that revenue stream for the
project do all public-private
partnerships include allowing the
private entity to have infrastructure
that they can monetize if there are
other options can you elaborate just a
lot of talk we get a lot of questions so
in general the using project finance you
know all of the costs to develop an
asset and maintain it for the long term
you know are accounted for so I guess to
answer your question the using this
procurement model the project has to be
fully funded and the the private company
that wins the contract and also
importantly the financier right the
source of debt financing for the project
is going to really scrutinize this
project to make sure it's fully funded
so by that metric they're the you know
they're there there has to be a source
of actual funding for a project that
uses this model and maybe I could
clarify just using this procurement
model in almost every case the private
partner isn't doesn't get ownership of
the infrastructure asset to mana
so usually it'll just be a long-term
contract in some cases it's there's you
know privatizations of the asset will be
transferred in ownership to the to the
contractor but in most cases it's not so
but I guess to answer your question yes
it's there they're there does have to be
a source of funding it's project what is
the strongest the strongest case you
made the government has incentive to
keep infrastructure supply in balance to
demand how can I do so without the use
of prices yeah that's an interesting
question
I mean there is a whole industry in and
around estimating the economic benefits
of infrastructure development and but
though that's a obviously a you know
part definitely there's a lot of science
there but there's also a little bit of
art in terms of estimating the benefits
to a government of developing a new
project it's it's difficult to tell you
know I I think in for some assets you
know there there can be pricing so I say
I do think that's part of the reason why
projects that are funded by a user fee
as opposed to general taxes it might be
a more efficient way of generating
funding for infrastructure because the
people that benefit from the project are
the people to pay for it now I think
there there should also be general
public you know support or funding
support for infrastructure so projects
shouldn't necessarily need to be just
using toll roads as an example they
shouldn't necessarily only need to be
funded by tolls because you know toll
roads also improve the economy and
you know improve commute times just ease
this as an example for people that don't
necessarily drive on on the toll road
and so because of that I think there's
definitely a case for general taxes but
to get to your question about the use of
prices that's why a lot of economists
have recommended user fee funding for
for toll roads or other infrastructure
because it does give a a direct
indication of demand do you have any
examples of grid modernization projects
that use p3 yeah there so this is a
relatively new sector I would say I
don't have a very good example in the
United States of a kind of a grid
modernization project there are some
related projects so state of Michigan
recently procured a contract to
essentially upgrade its lighting systems
on its fruits and freeways around
Detroit so that would be a the source of
funding for that project is essentially
the energy savings that the state's
going to have over the long term and I
think the the city of Washington DC is
also a process of procuring a street
lighting project Chicago has recently
procured a street lighting p3 so I think
that's a kind of a related grid upgrade
or pole upgrade project with a clear
source of funding through cost savings
so that would be a maybe a proxy
how about elaborating on infrastructure
financing for energy especially
distributed energy resources or a bee
charging yeah so there there there have
been so the I guess the the trouble with
more distributed projects or EB charging
projects for cities there have been some
smaller contracts to do that in the u.s.
in general I think those projects to
really use project finance or
to be procured as a public-private
partnership they they usually have to be
bundled in order because they're
generally kind of for smaller scale
projects but it the procurement model
could certainly be be used for those I
think the so for new technologies like
these sometimes this procurement model
can be slower to be adopted so in this
case you know if there's an Eevee
contract or kind of I believe it was a
distributed energy kind of a project so
the UM the most likely source of revenue
there of course will be you know energy
fees from users of those charging
stations or from the community and so
because it's a relatively new sector
it's kind of hard for companies to
really forecast that revenue or so in
some cases I would imagine for an Eevee
project if a city wants to pursue that
one of those using a public-private
partnership there might they might be
able to transfer some of that demand
risk to a private partner but also
potentially guarantee some payments over
the long term for the project so it's
possible but it's difficult for some new
technologies to really demand I think we
have time for about one more question
who is the right expert to help develop
legislation or a ballot initiative to
create an optimized version of the
Canada Australia special procurement
authority to encourage p3s a good
question to end on yeah so it's
interesting I mean they're you know
they're there there's lobbyists for the
infrastructure industry just like there
are a lot for for every industry and you
know there's there's certainly experts
that have have kind of looked at the you
know US federal policy in ways to
incentivize some of these and so I you
know I I think there's there's some some
expert groups out there on
infrastructure policy
you know I guess one of the factors of
course is that you know the agencies I
mentioned aren't necessarily federal
agencies although there have been some
good programs created like the Build
America Bureau at the federal government
you know these are state level agencies
so it's not necessarily DC that requires
some convincing but I think like those
state level agencies in Canada and
Australia
you know once once they were formed and
they developed a track record of
operating history you know they really
kind of took off from there so I think
what we'll see what happens with our
state level agencies here in the US and
and and one of my god on the limb great
that when I just thank you so much for
your time today we hope you enjoyed the
hour and encourage you to check out all
of our offerings at SCPD stanford.edu
and again don't forget you'll be
receiving a recording of this webinar to
share with your friends and colleagues
thanks so much for taking the time to
attend and have a great day